das mal auszuprobieren einfach aus ihm
an mit dem haken da hoch zu nehmen
also wenn das funktioniert anscheinend
noch ist er da
noch ist er da ja ihr schon mal rüber
gehen jetzt
servus kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute wieder mit mord
und wir haben heute eine neue videos
erklärt iris und zwar sammelt sebastian
soviel accounts wie er kann also bei
getjar folien wir werden wohl beide
schätzen wieviel accounts das sind und
derjenige der näher dran ist also besser
schätzt darf sich aussuchen was für
equipment fürs technisch gekauft wird
das rad und es geht darum dass wir
gucken uns natürlich am ende nach drei
ola lunde also am ende kurz vorm
shopping habe und ich fange einfach mal
an mit meinem guest ich sag ich hole
1000 100 coins ich sage du holst 909 100
coins ohm achse bietet mich damals
schnell vertrauten nicht in meine
fähigkeiten dabei bin ich doch dafür
bekannt den get down immer auszurasten
ich will einfach ich will wieder dafür
bekannt gut oder steht noch weder gut
noch schlecht zu spielen werden dafür
bekannt dass ich ausraste vorliegen auf
hits wie mario da hat man gar dem auch
schon auf name versucht und wir haben
sogar das glück dass diese wunderbare
karte wieder dabei auf gott aller die
kommt als nächstes wir haben natürlich
fahrerkarten forst merkt wie man es halt
so macht ein fries vom iphone geklickt
wird mit einer kerze junge ist war aber
eigentlich 18 er ist der erstplatzierte
18 118 abstand zehn.de verstand mit
einem desaster dem desktop dem thema
kein schaden ok oh là là noch schön
mitgenommen
632 kaum sein der erste runde ist gar
nicht so schlecht
der dunkle lord hd hat nur 40 könnte mir
obwohl er gefälscht hat roche sagte ich
möchte euch scheidet schreiben maxi
macken ich darf nicht rutschen auch
nicht aus spaß weil ihr es euch dann
angeboten
so schade das der logische runter
gefallen
den kann man dieser schein holen und
auch sehr schnell holen und da ist
wieder sommer der typ hat echt nerven
danke dir leipzig freut sich dass er
weggehen muss
ok das gefällt nicht dass gefällt schon
eher
das gefällt auch ich will den compaq
anja kaiser okay wie wir es hier mit der
sohn beim kampf an parteien dunkle lord
ist wieder am raschen der dunkle lord
wieder gar keine kunst ist perfekt genau
das bekommen 800 points das war jetzt
nicht so viel in dieser runde
eine prognose wann 908101 100 das heißt
wenn es 1000 sind es ist unentschieden
wenn es 999 sind habe ich gewonnen
august aber mir meine erzfeind ok um das
ökosystem g-power ein gebiss noch keinen
job fehlen nein ich bin ich noch gar
nicht gestorben könnte eigentlich sein
oh là là das sagt loos bitte wird die am
ende natürlich auch mal gar nicht so
schlecht so eine runde ohne jumps spiel
ein tipp schauen 981 werde ich diesen
blog schule und ich sterbe habe ich
diese challenge momentan für mich
entschieden und das selbst entscheiden
was ich gekauft wird man mag es mir
natürlich über welches mit equipment
rein drücken würde
so wie mir halt kennt denn mystic river
okay die dividende hat uns dabei ganz
guten stoff gegeben
sieht gut aus da oben war noch holzbock
dem will ich gerne ausweichen
und jetzt mal des finnischen den angriff
würde ich sagen ja
und sagt mit einem herz haben es gepackt
und es gibt 1273 darf bestimmen was
gekauft wird und die muss man in letzter
zeit macht mich die ansetzung ich viel
spaß eigentlich immer von der mep ab
sonst bin ich aber sagen ganz klassisch
schöne schwert extra herzen
ich habe keinen bogen von 30 sekunden
zeit menschen
ich sag's so jetzt kann ich mir
zumindest noch mal extra herz und
deutschland mitnehme und hier mal
schnell entscheiden
nochmals der offenen tür beim verbrennen
ist oder die verbrennung zweijahres ok
schärfe 3 ist jetzt in europa noch ganz
mehr verdrücken heute hier geht was
wasserläufer wasserläufer kann ich das
alles zu sein was du auf den ganzen
chipkarten kriegen kann vorher ist
entweder hier ist es nicht so top bei
dieser strand card also ziemlich gut ja
ok alles klar
dann packt man jetzt mal den chef würde
ich darum mich seinen kleinen endgegner
leckerste kannst auch ziemlich gut mit
der anderen spielen eigentlich eher
fällt ist schiff ist unendlich hoch
deine mitte tag da kann man tatsächlich
mit der angel einiges anstellen es ist
nicht die optimale karte für die angel
alter wasser läuft wieder ist stand gut
ausgesehen
ich bin schon den hier kann ich mir
schon schnell holen vor der kommt nicht
weghören
alter wasserläufer ist ok ach ja das
wusste ich aber das wird sich sowieso
vor ort dieser strand karte des op
wasserläufe in kombination mit einer
angel
wenn dann darum den humor hat sie haben
uns darum kämpft eine seiner der
top-manager kent auf dem bogen hatte
okay man das werde erst direkt dran
geholt da kommt jetzt erste gegner bis
zum besseren mit widmen
dass du mein freund von gerade eben er
konnte ist super mit der angel combo
unter wasser wenn man den wasserlauf hat
da kann man saugut combos mit der
anwärter wasser mal auf herz noch da
kann man saugen alter des op
wasserläufen einer der kanzler der combo
vergeben also sein bein po ebene ist
nicht so streng
da kannst du meister noch einen schönen
für hühnchen
da kannst du leute am meisten sommerhit
geben die mit der anderen schießt wenn
wir wieder schnell genug switches ok den
humus hätte würde ich sagen würde ich
auch sagen er kann nicht mehr viel am
kanada weg besser weg er hatte einen
sehr ordentlichen flame wars mir sagen
lassen können das wäre vor der andere
letzte gegner kommt ne ich weiß gar
nicht ob der so gut ist kümmern hat das
war heute schon stärker haltbarkeit
flamme gefällt mir ganz gut muss ich
sagen ich mal kurz raus okay das ist
eigentlich entschieden die eg hoch aus
watte europe sings auf schiffen 10 hoch
explosion fehlerfall alter wasserläufer
ist so geil beiersdorfer extrem so auf
dieser map wohl jetzt nicht alles okay
das kann alles nicht gebrauchen war kein
verbrennung 1 ich habe schon das beste
schweren der runde gehabt glaube ich ja
glaube ich haha was auf dem einbau wird
und der leider schon richtig ich sage
dir ein schweres weg
aber so wichtig ich spiele sogar hoch
gehen und versuchen weg zu höheren
verlust erwartet keinen fällt hier
stecken also verstehen hier hochkommt
spielverderber ohne dessen spielfeld der
aber ganz ehrlich kommt man ja ja ja ich
würde auch auf stichworte zu den
anrainern ja nicht blockieren komm
wieder wegkommt wenn du wenn du mich
dahin killers überlebst du denken wir
jetzt schon in den haken dran hängen da
mussten gleich treffen
das kann ich sagen die ganze mitnehmen
ja gut wenn er irgendwie zu weit weg ist
dann geht es nicht aber mir das mal
auszuprobieren aber aus ihm an mit dem
haken da hoch zu nehmen
als wenn das funktioniert noch noch ist
er da noch ist er da noch ist er da noch
ist er da ja ihr schon mal rüber gehen
jetzt liebt okay jetzt finde ich ihn so
sehr schöne aufgabe leute danke martin
ist dabei klar was ich noch sagen wollte
wenn euch irgendwelche get down
challenges einfallen könnte die gerne
mal die kommentare schreiben
damit nehmen wir die vielleicht meinen
die nicht mit rein und ihr werdet euch
erwähnt maxim verlinkt bis zum nächsten
video out rein und mineralwasser